germany is at the center of europe has
always been at this division line
between
the east and the west between nowadays
nato
and russia and now it's we see that this
whole regime to control nuclear arms
seems to be crumbling
is there a danger that there will be a
new cold war that there will be a new
arms race
well uh i wouldn't go as far as to say
that there is a new cold war
or a or an arms race there are tensions
this is obvious for everybody
i think the there is a recognition there
is a global recognition there is
there is a need to look into these
things that is
uh i would say a sort of a transition
from
arms control structures that were built
and created at the time of the
cold war so that reflected certain
strategic realities
and and and positionings of different
blocks and countries
of course i suppose that as in
any other area of the
world politics there has been an
evolution
and arms control is not of course except
exempted from that so i suppose what we
see is this transition
a transition is a time of of course
uncertainty but also opportunities
so do i understand you correctly you
would support
an attempt to make these treaties
multilateral rather than bilateral
between the united states and russia for
instance to include china
well as director general of the iaea
it wouldn't be correct for me to say
what countries should do all i can say
is that um the the
issue of nuclear weapons is a matter of
global concern
and and every country especially uh
countries that
have nuclear weapons have to recognize
that all of them
at the moment the whole world in a sense
is waiting for the elections of the
united states president do you think
that the result of that election will
have some effect on nuclear arms talks
well it is uh undeniable
that the politics and the cores of
uh politics and policies in
in the united states have an influence
on whatever we do here in europe in
germany
in international organizations so it
would be
hypocritical to say that there's nothing
that's going to come
out of it what matters uh i guess and i
think we are
pretty sure about this is that whoever
is the winner in the election uh the
united states will continue to be
a supporter a strong supporter of the
non-proliferation system which is
basically what my organization does and
i i am sure that this is going to be the
case
what about iran there too one gets the
sense that there is a kind of
hiatus at the moment that there's a
waiting period while
the election in the united states takes
place
is there a chance that if donald trump
loses the election there will be a new
impetus to dealing with iran
everybody is is waiting uh for
for the results of of that election um
there will be continuities and there
will be changes there will be
things that will be adapted even with
the same administration or with a new
one
but i think the jcpoa which is this
agreement that germany has been so
supportive of and i was
having a very interesting exchange with
the foreign minister ikomas
about it i think all of this will have
to be looked at
judging the these results but it's not
the only
thing i think there is a lot that the
rest can do on iran of course
as well to see to it that this process
jcpoa or no jcpoa continues in a
constructive
way what's the situation like on the
ground
in iran i mean your inspectors have been
having some trouble there doing their
work on the ground
this year is the situation in danger of
getting out of control is it
particularly dangerous at the moment
well let me say regarding what happened
this year this year was a difficult year
i
i would admit it there were some some
disagreements
between iran and the agency but we were
able to solve this
i think it was important um in short for
those who may not may not be aware
um our inspectors were not allowed to
visit a couple of sites which
which i consider to be very important um
so
after long negotiations we were able to
solve this now we're back in business
and we are working together uh in in
in this process which is a you know a
continuous process
that needs to uh go on so uh
we expect this uh to be the case do you
think there is a danger
an acute danger of things unraveling as
it were
in controlling iran in the tensions in
the region well there are factors that i
can control and factors that are
above my uh responsibility and have to
do
with the politics amongst nations
and this is not what the disease of the
iaea can control what i can tell you
is that we have a technical mandate to
inspect
that there is no deviation of nuclear
material to
the development of an atomic weapon
and this i can do this is something i
can do if
given the means to do it we are doing it
now we are collaborating
with iran but as as i just said
there are from time to time there are
some disagreements we have to solve them
we have to continue there's no other way
i'd like to turn to germany now germany
is i think the only country in the world
that has decided to get out of nuclear
energy
completely do you think what do you
think about that
that decision well it's it's it's uh
it's a very important decision that this
country took
uh a few years ago and like you say is
the country that is
moving on with it
seriously without hesitation at
at great speed so we are working
together
with germany the fact that germany is
leaving nuclear
energy generation doesn't mean that it's
not going to be working with the iaea in
the future there are lots of things we
do together
in the area of nuclear safety which is a
big concern
for germany because like it or not
germany is
surrounded by a continent and a world
where nuclear energy is like it or not
growing
so that's a reality and the only thing
that i suppose we have to make sure is
that whoever is in
is in this business does it at the
highest possible level of safety
and i think in this germany has an
enormous interest
you have also criticized the decision i
think
for climate change reasons you're saying
that i i believe
i i haven't if i may uh
correct you i haven't criticized the
decision what i'm saying
because each country is sovereign and
there's no
one size fit all in energy
what we are saying is that nuclear is
scientifically speaking part of the
solution
nuclear is a very extremely low
carbon emitter it's an energy
that it's it's it's dispatchable is
there
can work together with renewables
and the fact is that if you didn't have
nuclear energy imagine
100 reactors in the united states all
that you have in france
everywhere the co2 emissions
would skyrocket immediately so it is a
fact
we have to work together and and find
the solutions
as i have said the goal is to
decarbonize not to denuclearize well
decarbonized denuclearized obviously the
critics in germany would say
nuclear energy might not leave emissions
carbon emissions but
it leaves behind waste that needs to be
dealt with
and that is an equal problem indeed it's
a unique situation
but we do have the technology we do have
the means to deal with this
i'm not minimizing the fact that you
need social acceptability
nobody wants to be close to waste to any
waste
it's things you don't want to do it you
don't want to see it
it's normal the what the iea can do is
to
make sure that technologies are
developed to deal with this in a
sustainable
way there are different different views
we respect them all
the important thing is to compare nodes
and to work together in a future
oriented
perspective mr grossi thank you very
much for talking to deutsche weller
thank you it's been a pleasure it's been
a pleasure
you